in this video we will be studying the
vestibulocochlear nerve this video is
divided in two sections the first
section of the video deals with the
origin and the course of the
vestibulocochlear now and the second
section of this video deals with the
higher pathways that the neurons of the
vestibular baklanov follow as the
vestibulocochlear now arises from the
internal layer so let's just quickly
draw a diagram of the internal layer to
show you the origin of the
vestibulocochlear nerve now this is the
saccule above which plays the utricle
and this is the cochlea which contains
the organ the Corte within inner and the
outer hair cells in the cochlea part the
cochlear division of the
vestibulocochlear nerve it arises from
the inner and the outer hair cells
located in the organ of the cautery and
these fibers they unite to form the
cochlear division of the vestibular
cochlear nerve and vestibular division
it arises from the saccule arises from
the utricle and from the semicircular
canals and these fibers they first relay
in the vestibular ganglion
now this is the cochlear division of the
eighth nerve and this is the vestibular
division talking about the course of the
vestibulocochlear nerve now these fibers
are mainly situated in the inner
acoustic canal and these fibers are in
very close proximity to the facial nerve
and these fibers follow a very short
course and in the medial most part of
the internal acoustic and all these
fibers unite and form the veccio
cochlear nerve and they exit through the
internal cosas canal through the
internal meatus and follow a very short
intracranial course after which they
enter the brainstem at the level of T
pounds and the upper medulla so let's
just quickly draw a section of the pons
and the junction of the upper medulla
now it contains the various nuclei the
dorsal and the ventral cochlear nuclei
and the various when the vestibular
nuclei
the cochlear division of the
vestibulocochlear nerve enters the
dorsal and the ventral cochlear nuclei
and the vestibular division enters the
vestibular nuclei and from here onwards
these follow the higher pathways now
let's talk about the higher pathways
that these neurons follow to the
auditory cortex I was talking about the
auditory pathway these pathways begin
after the cochlear nerve enters the
dorsal and ventral cochlear nuclei which
are located in the upper medulla and
various nuclei are present in this
pathway and ultimately this pathway ends
in the auditory cortex let me just
quickly draw a diagrammatic depiction of
this pathway and then I will explain
this to you alright so as you can see
the pathway begins in the upper medulla
where the dorsal in the dorsal and
ventral cochlear nuclei are located and
the cochlear nerve enters these two
nuclei and from these two nuclei the
neurons ascend up into the superior
olivary nucleus and the neurons which
are sent up from the superior olivary
nucleus from the lateral meniscus and
they enter the inferior colliculus which
are located in the midbrain these two
are the inferior colliculi which are
located in the midbrain and the fibers
from the inferior colliculus they relay
into the medial geniculate body and the
neurons from the middle geniculate body
form the order irradiation which enters
into the auditory cortex there is a
simple mnemonic to remember this pathway
it is equal I ma e stands for is nerve
that is a vegetable cochlear nerve C
stands for the dorsal and ventral
cochlear nuclei o stands for superior
livery nucleus L for lateral a meniscus
I for the inferior colliculi and for the
medial geniculate body and a for the
auditory cortex now coming to the
vegetable pathway the vegetable pathway
is not as simple as that of the auditory
pathway in which the neurons just ascend
up to the auditory cortex now in this
pathway the main outlays that the
vestibular nerve first enters the
vestibule nuclei which are located at
the same level of the cochlear nuclei
and from these nuclei various neuron
pathways are formed and which are
related in the various centers of the
brain and spinal cord so as you guys
didn't see this vestibule and now it
first enters into the vestibular nuclei
and from these vestibular nuclei the
fibers first ascend up into the medial
longitudinal fasciculus to form the
medial longitudinal fasciculus or the
bundle and these ascend up into the
midbrain and the primary purpose of
these fibers is that they Anna they form
connection with the motor neurons of the
third fourth and the sixth cranial
nerves so as you know that the these
nerves are responsible for the movements
of the eye so this links the vestibular
pathway to the movements of the eye and
result in nystagmus
now some fibers of these ascend up into
the cerebellum and this if is known as
the vestibular cerebellar pathway which
is very important in control of gait and
balance now some fibers from the
vestibular nuclei descend downwards as
the vestibular spinal tract so friends
this was a simplified version of the
vestibulocochlear nerve I hope you find
this video informative and please make
sure to hit the like button below and
also make sure to subscribe and share
this video thank you for watching